[Music]
honey she's an artist she is the history
of fashion like no other designer she's
a legend modern graphic
she's explosive
yes I'm sure your gratitude is quite
inexpressible I first encounter Edna's
work I remember sitting in Paris
along darling Lila hmm she's very
intimidating outrageous you look ghastly
right Edna's a divisive figure cycle in
siog Louis Vuitton Edna she's a
visionary a giant I mean well not
literally she comes up to my knees my
favorite add new pieces the nuclear ones
the rocket stilettos everyone has said
the bees don't ask me to do it again
darling my rates are far too have you
ever heard anything so devious and they
can't all pull it off I'm not all dark
and angsty Elastigirl
Edna designed this no some guy named
Alexander gehlbach I would say Edna mode
is like the modern-day Andy Warhol but I
think Andy Warhol looked up to her bravo
Bravo darling no bill will be covered by
my feet for being mr. incredible
Elastigirl and frozen's exclusive
designer throughout the known universe
until the
[Music]
I thought we were gonna get heard your
mother trampolining
superheroes are illegal you wanna fight
bad guys defines Who I am
we're not saying you have what someone
on TV said I was approached by this
tycoon must talk about hero stuff help
me bring supers back into the sunlight
we need Elastigirl
[Music]
there's no problem not the way you're
supposed to do it - they want us to do
it I don't know that way why would they
change math over Dusseldorf do those are
diverging
I was so happy to be closer I could have
done this if you hadn't taken over so
well I've got to succeed so she can
succeed but I can't keep giving it done
properly parenting is a heroic act done
properly
[Music]